on a créé une chose probablement unique
dans toute l'histoire de l'humanité
court jusqu'au on a créé un paradis sur
terre
incroyable ce qu'on est en train
d'accomplir les enfants sont merveilleux
elles montrent maintenant il faut que
maman reste à l'hôpital pour l'instant
comment elle va
on est une famille les semis et des
managers qui s'élance fois que j'appelle
la police
ils veulent pas de nous à l'enterrement
on doit dire qu'on veut voir notre maman
cette fois ci c'est votre baptême du feu
mettez votre entraînement à profit ils
sont des autos du film du coup y'a du
poison en bouteille
vient en tout cas je suis très heureuse
que notre famille nous c'est que du bio
et du local les poulets tu les as tu es
avec moi une hache pour un coût de 1 20
heures je suis allé à la boucherie j'ai
acheté les poulets sur une île était
déjà mort les enfants ont besoin d'un
cadre d'aller à l'école suivre de vrais
coups ni dans les 30 euros j'espère que
vous étiez pas en train de faire ce que
je crois que vous étiez en train de
faire votre fille m'a appris bien des
choses ce soir
veux tu m'épouser ne sort pas d'avocat
je connais rien solennel
même s'ils survivent à tout ce que tu
leur fait subir ils finiront par être
totalement incapable de s'adapter au
monde rêve
figurez-vous que moi je pense exactement
le contraire c'est de la maltraitance
vous avez failli me toucher si j'avais
voulu de toucher je t'aurais touchés
habillez moi nous avons décidé de
demander la garde des enfants
tu crois qu'ils te retire aux médias
c'est bien possible nos enfants seront
des philosophes roi et cela me procure
un bonheur indescriptible